merde
laisse-moi ralentir oh oui s'il te plait
je viens de réaliser que tu enregistrais ouais
tu sais je viens de détruire le fait d'
essayer d'être faible sur lui oui s'il te plait ouais ouais
même jusqu'à environ deux heures il y a
une pente là-bas avec eux ouais on dirait
vraiment, nous nous contentons de selle là-bas,
ouais,
si nous tournons l'hélicoptère vers la droite
et que cette pente s'éloigne juste en dessous de la
crête de la crête, là-bas,
presque au milieu de la photo, maintenant,
nous aurons plus de l'autre côté de toute façon,
juste pendant la croisière  ouais, il y a des petites
taches de couleur,
il y en avait plus avant, j'étais en fait
comme un problème en ce moment, va là où tu
regardes, tu as pointé, ok,
ouvre à 12 heures vers l'hélicoptère,
ok, ouais, voilà, il est un
peu 12 heures maintenant et  quelques kilomètres
et nous traverserons cette colline là-bas,
je ne sais pas si cela va fonctionner
comme vous l'envisagez,
nous allons essayer,
que diriez-vous d'en bas, là-bas, en bas, c'est
encore mieux ouais,
probablement plus facile  pour que tu voles ouais,
alors je me suis mis un peu à gauche et
ensuite nous ferons le tour autour de lui, comment ça va, je
veux le récupérer plus au sud, ça a l'
air vraiment sympa de cette façon, tu peux en
avoir quelques minutes oui, c'est
vrai  tu enregistres maintenant je ne pensais pas avoir
enregistré ouais ok eh bien
on va y aller ouais
sur ce gros morceau de feuilles rouges
tout droit sorti de nous oui entendu devant nous
ok
le Peter ouais était juste au milieu
qui traversait l'autre image ouais
mais cette petite grange est si mignonne c'est
comme ça que j'aimerais vivre je
peux le faire Peter je vais euh l'amener un
peu à ma gauche ici ouais ouais je vais
l'aligner pour qu'on passe tout droit
cette route et continuer au-dessus de la
colline, ouais, d'accord, alors quand vous arrivez à la
crête, près de Crest, ceux qui
colorent les pentes vont en quelque sorte très
lentement, car vous pouvez aller plus lentement, cela vous mord à cause
des trucs colorés que
nous allons tourner  c'est vrai légèrement,
je veux le ramasser maintenant ou ouais c'est
bien, dégage les maisons ouais
un fil traverse c'est toujours bien les
couleurs sont vraiment belles ici ouais je
veux monter jusqu'au point le plus élevé de
la colline ici oui s'il te plaît ouais ouais tout
droit  comme sur la bonne bonne route
avec euh le cumulus est là-haut
sur les
couleurs ressemblent à la boîte de Fruit Loops oh
c'est vraiment sympa
quels sont les fils qui passent là-bas ouais
il y a des fils ouais là-bas
ouais nous devrions avoir une course claire juste
c'est comme
ouais  Je ne peux aller nulle part ouais
et nous referons exactement la même
chose mais nous ferons des plans plus proches et plus rapprochés ouais
ok c'est
magnifique
maman continue jusqu'à ce que ça
monte ouais
30 secondes sur ce truc ouais ouais boucle
autour et  refaire le même genre de course,
j'ai failli le perdre ici, mais continuez simplement à
franchir la crête pendant encore 15
secondes, puis faites une boucle,
mais les pêches et aussi pour les montagnes de Casco,
oh
d'accord, il y a encore 10 bonnes boucles autour,
hein,
j'arrête d'enregistrer  pour la mienne,
je peins cette maison ici,
c'est aussi une belle maison,
d'accord, ouais, prête à partir, oh
ce gars, tout comme les arbres, les
arbres, c'est vrai,
mais comme tous les arbres de la version bêta, y a-t-il
des cieux,
ouais, en ce moment,
je vois du ciel dans ma  ça dérange ou pas, ok, eh
bien, nous avons un peu de coupure
là-bas, ok ouais, je suis masqué, ok,
étranger,
je regarderai directement les
mêmes arbres oui s'il te plaît ouais,
c'est comme le rêve américain,
mon rêve,
c'est tous les Américains.  stream pour être honnête
mais j'espère qu'autour du soleil, nous y
reviendrons dans une
seconde ouais maintenant tu ne veux pas être aussi
bas, correct ouais ouais un peu plus haut,
c'est trop haut c'était  probablement une bonne
hauteur, je vais continuer à m'incliner sur
les choses actuelles,
pivoter sur euh,
ils obtiennent cette zone dégagée à
droite, d'accord,
les étrangers
font un grand angle en pensant à l'endroit où vous voyez
la grange et les arbres à l'arrière ouais, euh,
qu'est-ce que c'est  ça continue après ouais ok
donc nous tu penses qu'on devrait faire un autre
cercle avec un objectif plus large
je ferai exactement la même chose donc
même trajectoire de vol encore
ok je vais le laisser sortir et évidemment
les dérapages
ouais j'ai compris merci
non, il joue sur les lignes électriques, pas
de problème, c'est
bon, je
roule à nouveau, je ne suis jamais assez, il y a
quelqu'un de vieux et de malade ou quoi que ce soit
dans la maison,
symétrie,
[ __ ] de
coup régulier, démarrez l'autre,
je pense que nous manquons de bienvenue,
ok, nous sommes  fait ici, nous continuons à rouler
ouais ouais
peut-être retourner sur les arbres comme un grand
angle comme ça ouais
continue de grimper sur cette frappe et puis
tourne à droite reviens sur la piste d'origine
euh nous avons juste fini
je vais faire un autre coup d'oeil vers le bas  à
haute altitude, d'accord, côté vertical, ton
tir vertical ouais,
je pense, peux-tu imaginer à quoi ressemble cette ville.
Préparation centrale qui est à environ sept
miles aujourd'hui à
l'est de nous,
ok, commence à tourner maintenant, il tourne
à droite,
ouais, laisse-moi faire le tour de cette maison et
nous installer.  de la façon dont nous l'avons fait,
nous sommes à six milles à l'ouest de Lexington, une
ville assez sympa ouais, je
vais m'incliner ouais nous le ferons ouais à mesure que nous nous en
rapprochons ouais,
je n'ai pas juste un script à droite
parce qu'il y a  plus de couleur comme ça ok
merci
ok
ouais un peu plus ouais jusqu'à 50.
ok ok merci
j'étais par ici
j'étais simplement Réservoir nous faisons ça
comme le coin nord-est de ce lac
là tu as ça juste ici alors nous
sommes  ces arbres au milieu de cette
île, c'est plutôt sympa, ça pourrait être aller
tout droit au-dessus de la petite île là-bas
avec les arbres dedans ouais il
y a de moins en moins d'eau dedans
allons plus bas là-bas ouais
tapez les gens ici comme des quatre
roues  ou quelque chose
oh
juste trop bas pour toi ouais c'était l'
excellent ouais ouais
donc ce n'est pas pour New York, euh c'est
local dans le nord de l'
État de New York ouais je sais mais euh quelle
ville ressemble autour de la région d'Utica ouais
ouais j'ai besoin d'un
euh  c'estvrai,
ça pourrait être le comté de Delaware,
je pense que c'est le Delaware ouais, je pense que c'est
United et c'est tout quand nous sommes à l'
aéroport, cela
ressemble à une plage
mais les gens ont des bateaux et tout, ouais,
quelqu'un n'avait pas prévu que l'eau
descende si vite.  c'est
vrai,
Gilligan's Island Austin juste là, je
veux en quelque sorte aller là-bas ouais
tout droit ou souvent je n'ai pas besoin de
voir ce qui est bien si personne n'obtient mon numéro
ici, ils ne peuvent pas supposer qui c'est
près de moi
tout droit maintenant et  au-dessus de la plage
et au-dessus,
vous resterez bas, allez bas au-dessus de ces arbres
qui, euh, ont un peu de couleur dessus juste un
peu à une heure du
rendez-vous de l'avion,
oh
mon Dieu,
étranger,
ok peut-être euh si nous si nous volons vers  un grand
cercle à droite ici, faites une autre course
tout droit vers le réservoir.
Je vais vous dire ce que je vais vous dire, laissez-moi continuer
tout droit parce qu'après la pluie, ici, nous
avons une zone de couleurs plus longue, d'accord
et je suppose que c'est là que vous vraiment
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais un autre euh
entre ces euh ces plantations
je veux dire je vais aller après la droite ici ok
oui s'il te plait ouais très bien montons un
peu plus loin parce qu'il y a comme un
marais qui descend ici ça doit être le
Riverland juste il y a un  maison
en dessous de nous ouais ouais tu vois ça
parce que tu ne veux pas beaucoup de ces
arbres verts, n'est-ce pas, nous
allons sortir de cette petite rivière
ok
ouais ouais d'accord alors je vais tourner à
droite ok
arrête d'enregistrer ça en regardant  ici
où est cette merde oh c'est derrière nous
excellent ok je l'ai mis là
je dirai que je suis probablement ouais et euh nous sommes en
quelque sorte au coin de la rue et il
s'ouvre en quelque sorte juste en bas sur le
lit de l'écran puis
zoome un peu  plus pour que nous puissions voir la
rivière que
je descends maintenant ouais, je te comprends,
comme tu viens de le voir, ils s'inclineront
lentement donc ça s'est écoulé au moment où je descendrai dans
le lit de la rivière, je regarderai l'
horizon
ouais  c'est un joli cliché
et puis avec un réservoir quand tu viens en quelque sorte
vers le Roosevelt en ce moment
ouais nous allons bien,
je veux dire tu vas bien
exploser ouais
et continue le
tir
ouais
je vais te dire ce que je  Je vais te faire traverser directement
et il y a un tuyau qui mène au
réservoir juste en face de
nous, d'accord ouais,
j'ai besoin d'un bateau ponton
et je commence à grimper un peu, ouais, tu
fais ça,
oh, il est comme quand ils prennent
des photos et ils nous font signe.  au lieu de
l'option
merci
ok eh bien c'est bien ok marche dessus
ouais on se met en hauteur
ne prends pas si longtemps pour changer la cassette
euh je vais déconner régler le code
punk tête haute
et on va survoler  tu sais
encore ce petit coup
après
qu'on sache quand tu penses que tu es assez défoncé
ouais probablement juste tu continues à te calmer
mais continue à nous faire frapper pendant un moment
jusqu'à ce que je
m'éloigne un peu de la foutue
seconde où ce n'est pas bien où nous sommes  pas juste
au-dessus, nous pouvons tourner et nous en
approcher à nouveau
et vous devez commencer à tourner à
gauche maintenant mais j'en aurai un pour passer le barrage,
mais d'accord, laissez-moi aller là-bas à la place
ou sortir un peu plus loin  euh
toi tu gardes euh où suis-je et là
nous cherchons il y a un barrage juste par
ta fenêtre gauche ouais
ouais ok